le palais de marivent end dans les
baléares la résidence d'été de la plus
célèbre famille d'espagne la famille
royale
comme tous les ans depuis 38 ans elle
prend la pose pour sa traditionnelle
photo de vacances une famille idéale
trois générations unis autour du roi
juan carlos
icône des espagnols symbole de la
démocratie dans le pays
le couple royal leurs enfants marié et
des petits princes qui font le bonheur
des photographes
cette jolie photo date de 2007 la
monarchie est alors à son apogée
c'est la dernière qu'ils feront tous
ensemble depuis la famille a éclaté et
le royaume espagnol est ébranlée par une
série de scandales
un roi qui mène grand train et par au
bout du monde tuer des éléphants dans
des safaris hors de prix
[Musique]
une reine humilié depuis des années par
les infidélités supposées de juan carlos
un gendre qui aurait détourné des
millions d'euros et risquent aujourd'hui
dix ans de prison
comment en est on arrivé là
pourquoi juan carlos le roi populaire
est il devenu un roi maudit
nous allons vous raconter la chute d'une
famille qui s'est cru invulnérable
enquête sur le crépuscule d'un roi
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le palais royal à madrid et la résidence
officielle des rois c'est ici qu'ils
accomplissent l'essentiel de leur
activité publique une forteresse aux
traditions a changé depuis des siècles
nous voulons approché la famille royale
pour cela nous nous accréditons après un
mois de vérifications
on nous accepte parmi la quarantaine de
journalistes de la presse royal toutes
les semaines on nous enverra l'agenda de
la couronne et les activités auxquelles
nous pouvons assister premier jour et
première convocation
une parade militaire
c'est juan carlos le roi qui s'y colle
les défilés c'est son rayon
il est le chef des armées en espagne
mais après 38 ans au garde à vous le roi
commence à vaciller sur ses béquilles le
premier des espagnols n'est plus que
l'ombre de lui-même souvent à l'hôpital
ses apparitions n'attire plus que
quelques journalistes et une poignée
d'irréductibles elles ne durent jamais
plus d'une dizaine de minutes
[Musique]
jours suivants la presse a rendez-vous à
l'opéra de madrid avec le prince
héritier felipe et la princesse letizia
jeunes et beaux ils sont les mannequins
royaux la vitrine de la monarchie le
prince felipe et sportif
éduqué aux états unis formés pour
succéder un jour à son père sa femme
laeticia est une ancienne star de la tv
ex présentatrice de jt c'est aujourd'hui
une icône de la mode en espagne pour le
rendez vous d'après nous sommes
convoqués au salon des animaux de
compagnie avec la reine sophie vous
savez moi j'ai un bichon maltais dans
l'espagne royal la femme du monarque
doit s'occuper de bonnes oeuvres de
charité et d'animaux j'adore les chats
les pousses du roi d'espagne est aussi
fille du roi de grèce
pourquoi vous l'avez rasé comme ça elle
est née pour ce rôle en aristocrate
professionnels elles assurent le
spectacle au milieu de la foule et des
photographes
car à chaque fois c'est le même rituel
pour la presse nous sommes strictement
encadré
j'apporte à une maison là-bas avec tous
les autres héros
cherchant une place trop bas une
quinzaine de gardes du corps nous
tiennent à distance contrôler son image
dans ses moindres détails
c'est l'obsession de la famille royale
pour mieux comprendre comment la
monarchie fabrique son image nous allons
suivre un habitué de ce club très fermé
roberto est un photographe espagnol
accrédités à la couronne depuis des
années aujourd'hui c'est un rendez vous
traditionnel qu'il ne manque jamais au
palais les audiences du prince felipe
alors comme d'habitude c'est veste et
cravate obligatoire pour travailler
c'est parce qu'il est plus pratique mais
il faut respecter les règles sinon il te
met dehors tout simplement ton apparence
mais aussi ton comportement est contrôlé
il est interdit d' adresser la parole
aux membres de la famille royale est
encore plus de leur poser une question
c'est silence absolu en costume cravate
tu fais tes photos c'est un autre monde
c'est différent
roberto et ses collègues ont rendez vous
à l'entrée de la zarzuela un autre
palais des rois située un peu en dehors
de madrid
sur place interdiction de prendre sa
voiture tout le monde est embarqué dans
un bus à la famille royale ne veut pas
d'image volet de sa propriété
nous arrivons à la salle d audience
comme d'habitude ce sont les gardes du
corps qui installent des journalistes
les gars vous reculez vous restez bien
au fond leurs altesses royales les
princes des asturies première audience
du jour les princes reçoivent les
meilleurs élèves d'un collège du sud de
l'espagne
roberto et ses collègues ont trois
minutes pour tout photographier
silence absolu personne n'a le droit de
parler ou d'interpeller le couple
princier
ni les photographes ni même les invités
les gars en arrière en or à part les
ordres des gardes du corps on entend que
les crépitements des appareils photos
allez on sort en sort
les journalistes sont raccompagnés dans
l'antichambre ils vont devoir patienter
une heure avant la prochaine session
c'est toujours ce rythme et c'est très
répétitif on attend des heures pour
quelques minutes
nouvelle entrée princière nouvelle
poignée de main le même ballet absurde
et silencieux se reproduit trois fois de
suite à l'identique
avec des professeurs d'université ou
avec des enfants handicapés
[Musique]
de retour chez lui roberto envoie ses
photos à son agence lice ultra contrôlé
elle donne au final une image très
positive du couple princier
je crois que la photo du jour va être
celle là
ce qu'ils se regardent qu'ils ont un
geste ferait charmant les parce
qu'aujourd'hui c'est leur anniversaire
de mariage et on peut parier que tous
les journaux vont titre et les princes
ont fêté leur anniversaire de mariage en
travaillant pas question de risquer une
image différente
la presse espagnole ne publie que des
photos favorables à la famille royale
roberto en a fait l'expérience il y a
deux ans j'ai fait ces trois photos qui
montrent vous voyez que la princesse ne
va pas bien qu'elle n'est pas en bonne
santé elle a des troubles de
l'alimentation
elle n'est pas que maigre elle est
clairement obsédé par les régimes et
cette photo n'a jamais été vendu en
espagne mais elle a été publiée en
allemagne
ça montre bien ce qui est permis ou pas
on ne peut pas évoquer l'anorexie de la
princesse ce sont des choses qui ne se
disent pas dans ce pays une
communication ultra verrouillée avec de
belles images à la une des journaux
pourtant en avril 2012 une simple photo
comme un grain de sable va gripper toute
la machine le portrait de juan carlos
posant devant le cadavre d'un éléphant
leroy revient d'un safari luxueux à
45000 euros la semaine
la photo fait la une de tous les
journaux ces vacances devait rester
secrète mais le roi s'est brisé la
hanche au cours d'une chasse il a été
rapatrié en urgence à ses côtés sur la
photo
l'organisateur de ces safaris
sur le site internet de sa société voici
les chasses qu'il vente à sa clientèle
vip est existe un endroit où les géants
se promènent en liberté
bienvenue dans le delta d'okavango et
bienvenue au paradis
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
un safari 5 étoiles où des chasseurs
fortune et abattent des éléphants
un hobby étrange pour le roi d'un pays
en faillite et accessoirement le
président du vvf espagnol
la petite escapade de juan carlos va se
transformer en affaire d'état
car la photo choc en profondeur même
chez les monarchistes les plus
convaincus c'est dans les quartiers
populaires fidèle au roi depuis toujours
que juan carlos a le plus perdu de ses
soutiens trois gros et un de ces
monarchistes déçu sans emploi depuis
trois ans le jeune homme vit avec son
frère au chômage lui aussi et son neveu
dans l'appartement de leur mère elle
touche une retraite de 500 euros par
mois sur laquelle ils vivent tous alors
le safari royal a du mal à passer
cet argent que cette famille getty alors
qu'on pourrait en faire autre chose
c'est ça qui nous a fait réaliser
on s'est dit mais pourquoi on donne tant
d'argent à cette famille ils en ont pas
besoin
nous devons tous louent des terres de
l'argent tout tu te dis mais pourquoi
moi on est pas un peu des millions
d'espagnols vivent la même situation que
la famille de juanjo 27% de la
population est au chômage et survit sans
aucune aide de l'état
toutes les semaines poindre on en est
réduit à récupérer de la nourriture
gratuite dans les banques alimentaires
qui ont réapparu un peu partout point de
croo a pourtant toujours travaillé avant
il était commerçant mais regardez j'ai
travaillé et cotisé pendant 16 ans la
sécu ces gens c'est pas les histoires là
ça fait plus de deux ans je suis au
chômage mais cela parce que je veux pas
bosser le travail il y en a plus prendre
aux dépens de sa grand mère parce
qu'elle est âgée c'est elle qui a droit
à l'aide alimentaire
j'ai vécu la guerre quand j'étais petit
mes jeux les mieux vécu qu'aujourd'hui
parce qu'à l'époque je ne devais pas moi
et ma nourriture
il ya du poulet c'est tout ce qu'on a
aujourd'hui
ainsi c'est bon t'as tout tu peux
l'emporter maintenant la nourriture que
juanjo à récupérer vient d'un
supermarché du quartier qui donne ses
invendus
mais les patates au fond du sac la crise
est profonde elle va venir à bout de
l'incroyable popularité du roi pendant
ces 38 ans de règne points de carlos a
bénéficié de 90% d'opinions favorables
pourquoi le monarque était il aussi aimé
pour le comprendre il faut remonter aux
années 30 jusqu'à la fracture la plus
profonde de l'histoire espagnole
la guerre civile elle éclate en 1936 le
général franco fait tomber la république
et installe une dictature d'extrême
droite qui va durer 40 ans
[Musique]
novembre 1948 sur un quai de gare
juancarlos entre en scène
ce petit garçon c'est lui à 10 ans il
est le fils d'un roi en exil les hommes
de franco sont venus le chercher
le dictateur l'a réclamé pour rencontrer
un spécialiste de cette période il faut
aller à londres
paul preston est le seul historien avoir
écrit une biographie fouillée de juan
carlos et de facto briques et nat
il a été littéralement kidnappé par
franco c'est comme s'ils avaient été
vendus en esclavage par ses parents
parce qu'en 1948
franco a passé un marché avec son père
soit vous m'envoyer votre fils pour que
je les lèvres en espagne soit il ne sera
jamais roi et youmna va va à vau bécret
franco n'a pas de fils pour lui succéder
alors il va se charger personnellement
de l'éducation de juan carlos tout
l'éducation de juan carlos va tourner
autour de l'obsession de franco la plus
importante perpétuer le régime de l'ag
franco mentor de juan carlos il va même
le protégé lors d'un événement terrible
et méconnu qui aurait pu lui coûter son
trône
[Musique]
4 avril 1956 on enterre le petit frère
de juan carlos alfonso tué d'un coup de
revolver
juan carlos est là en uniforme
il a 18 ans dans le cortège personne ne
s'en doute mais c'est lui qui a tué son
frère frank o va le couvrir d'après la
version officielle validé par le
dictateur lui-même alfonso se serait tu
es tout seul un accident en nettoyant
son arme
[Musique]
le drame s'est joué ici au deuxième
étage d'une maison de famille au
portugal alors qu'ils jouaient tous les
deux
juancarlos tir involontairement une
balle dans la tête d'alphonse haut
l'historien paul preston est le premier
à avoir révélé cette affaire
j'ai fait une reconstitution de cet
événement le bras de juan carlos a sans
doute était déviée par une porte qui
s'est ouverte et le coup est parti comme
ça pour terrasser shy'm et sur les
détails exacts il n'y a qu'une seule
personne qui connaît la vérité haïti n'a
en fait j'ai posé la question en
revanche je lui ai demandé si ma version
des faits était correct il m'a dit c'est
vrai
étouffé par franco la sphère est encore
tabou en espagne juan carlos en gardera
une dette envers le dictateur à qui il
rendra hommage régulièrement comme dans
une interview pour la télévision suisse
en 1970 pour vous personnellement que
représente le général franco
pour moi c'est un exemple vivant jours à
jour par son dévouement patriotique
envers en service de l'espagne
et à part ça il est j'ai pour lui une
très grande affection et admiration
juancarlos fidèles de franco le
dictateur d'extrême droite
il va devenir son successeur en novembre
banyoles
flamenco
à moult ce jour-là juan carlos est le
premier à venir saluer la dépouille du
dictateur
le soir même la monarchie est rétabli il
est proclamé roi d'espagne
[Applaudissements]
je jure devant dieu et les seins de
l'évangile de respecter les lois du
royaume et de rester fidèle aux
principes du mouvement national
c'est alors un retournement historique
sans précédent sous la pression
internationale et celle de la société
les barons du franquisme accepte un
changement de régime
des élections sont organisées les partis
interdits sous la dictature sont de
retour c'est aussi une ère d'incertitude
et de tensions très fortes
le roi va se transformer en rempart en
1978 la nouvelle constitution en fait un
personnage clé
chef de l'état il est inviolable et
irresponsable
le 23 février 1981 l'espagne va en faire
son héros
[Musique]
un militaire tir en plein parlement
c'est un coup d'état
les ultras du franquisme eux veulent
reprendre le pouvoir
l'espagne panique croyant revivre la
guerre civile
rocé luis zapatero ancien premier
ministre avait 18 ans à l'époque je me
rappelle parfaitement ce jour là non
j'étais étudiant en droit à l'époque
j'étais en train de préparer un examen
de finances publiques et tout à coup on
a appris l'italien
comment des militaires prennent d'assaut
le parlement notre souveraineté
nationale est attaqué un riff une fois
de plus dans l'histoire espagnole et la
manche on était très inquiet
et puis on a vu le roi
en pleine nuit juancarlos annonce à la
télévision qu'il a mis fin au coup
d'état
la pologne la couronne ainsi symbole de
la permanence et de l'unité de la patrie
ne peut tolérer d'aucune façon les
actions de personnes qui prétendent
utiliser la force pour interrompre le
processus démocratique l'instant va
électriser tous les espagnols
même à gauche vous a pas d re n'avait
pas le profil d'un monarchiste
socialiste petit fils d'un républicains
fusillés
il devient pourtant ce jour là un des
plus fidèles admirateurs du roi
d'espagne est tombée amoureuse du roi le
23 février les plus grands pays
les grandes nations doivent savoir
reconnaître les moments les plus
importants de leur histoire faut surtout
reconnaître les hommes à qui elles
doivent ces moments-là relie le roi a
joué le premier rôle dans le plus beau
moment de l'histoire espagnole
cette nuit là le 23 février 1981
juan carlos est il vraiment sauvé à lui
tout seul la démocratie un pays entier
en tout cas décide de se raconter cette
histoire
gilles tremlett et le correspondant du
guardian à madrid depuis les années 80
non pas pour éviter le retour du pire il
fallait que le roi comme institution est
une image forte et c'est à ce moment là
qu'un pacte a été passé entre la presse
les politiques et la couronne elle-même
pour construire une image du roi comme
celle du sauveur de la patrie pour faire
de lui un homme quasi parfait et c'est
cette image idéale que les petits
espagnols continuent d'apprendre dès
leur plus jeune âge
[Musique]
valladolid
une cérémonie de remise de prix scolaire
on récompense les lauréats du concours
national
c'est quoi un roi pour toi comme partout
en espagne
chaque année des dizaines d'écoliers
sont réunis avec leurs parents pour ce
rituel autour de la monarchie celui qui
va représenter la communauté de castille
et leon pour le grand concours du roi à
madrid
c'est je fais monter un peu le suspense
c'est christine 1,16 à raul à la tribune
le représentant de l'éducation nationale
car ce concours est parrainé depuis 38
ans par le ministère
[Musique]
ces travaux sur le roi sont réalisés en
classe sous l'égide des professeurs
c'est d'ailleurs le représentant du
ministère qui vient féliciter les
enfants pour leur découpage
j'ai mis toutes les phrases importante
que le roi a dit c'est quoi ta phrase
préférée celle là pour aider les
chômeurs et leurs familles
très bien moi je les fais comme un super
héros qui sauve l'espagne de la crise
avec lui le chômage se termine il y a
plus d'argent dans les écoles très bien
un concours d'écoliers qui tient
clairement du culte de la personnalité
je pense que les rois n'aime pas trop
l'argent c'est ce qu'on apprend à
l'école
oui on apprend que c'est quelqu'un de
très humble de très proche du peuple
et qu'il peut nous aider en tout point
nationale et c'est ton professeur
d'histoire qui t'apprend ça oui et
qu'est ce que tu en penses
ce que j'adore l'histoire et j'aime
apprendre des choses sur l'espagne à un
souverain modeste est proche de son
peuple
une famille unie un roi sauveur de son
pays
c'est la propagande d'état au menu dans
toutes les écoles une histoire
officielle
digérée par plusieurs générations et que
personne jusque là n'avaient remise en
question jusqu'à ce fameux safari 18
avril 2012
de retour du botswana
juan carlos se fait opérer ici après son
accident de chasse face à l'indignation
il a compris qu'il fallait un signe fort
votre majesté
comment vous sentez vous s'il vous plaît
ça va mieux je veux remercier tout le
personnel médical et la clinique pour
ses soins j'ai hâte de retourner à mes
obligations et je suis vraiment désolé
j'ai fait une erreur ça ne se reproduira
plus d excuse royal un fait sans
précédent dans l'histoire de la
monarchie
la scène va frapper l'opinion mais il
est trop tard
signe des temps pour la première fois le
roi est tournée en dérision
pas trop majesté comment vous sentez
vous très bien merci
je suis désolé je m'excuse d'être tombé
ça ne se reproduira plus la prochaine
fois je regarderai où je mets les pieds
leroy objet de caricatures chose
impensable il ya à peine quelques mois
silence sur le plateau moteur action
nous sommes sur le plateau de paulownia
à barcelone une émission satirique
catalan la première est encore la seule
à oser parodier le roi le sketch
d'aujourd'hui met en scène trois carlos
et sa fille j'ai pas envie j'ai pas
envie de donner mon argent aux impôts
en plus c'est un argent que j'ai gagné à
la sueur du fond de tous les espagnols
il ya sûrement moyen d'avoir des
déductions regarde il ya peut-être une
case empêcher un coup d'état joanne
rufas et le scénariste de l'émission
après l affaire du safari
son personnage du roi a fait exploser
les audiences ne voudrais pas nous
donner une médaille mais je crois que
notre émission à normaliser la monarchie
en mettant en scène le roi toutes les
semaines en faisant des gags sur lui en
le caricaturant sur sa situation
politique ça a changé la donne c'est à
donner la possibilité aux gens de parler
sans avoir peur
dans la foulée la presse espagnole se
lâche
elle aussi et révèlent tous les petits
secrets du roi comme cette femme corinna
dont le visage apparaît un peu partout
la mystérieuse amie du roi titre vanity
fair elle serait d'après le journal une
des maîtresses de juan carlos elle était
avec lui au safari
corinne à une princesse allemande
travaillant dans la com dans les soirées
où même les voyages officiels
elle n'est jamais très loin du roi
la princesse corinna vivrait depuis
plusieurs années en espagne
elle aurait même sa maison à quelques
kilomètres de la zarzuela le palais où
vivent les rois une petite villa aurait
été aménagé à monter del pardo dans une
propriété royal géré par le patrimoine
national
l'endroit est entièrement clos est
interdit au public
bonjour c'est ici la maison de corinna
non la princesse n'habite pas ici
non vous êtes volontés d'alberto
pourtant on m'a dit que c'était ici
qu'elle habitait là elle habite ou alors
non je ne sais pas
j'en ai aucune idée c'est quoi alors ici
ici c'est montés del pardo
c'est une zone réservée réservé pour qui
pour les animaux mais les voisins qui
passent par là semble en savoir un peu
plus pardon monsieur vous savez où est
la maison de corinne ah oui c'est au
fond tout droit comment vous le savez et
te sont ici c'est un village et dans un
village on s'est tous les gens vivent
ici depuis toujours en semoule parlent
entre eux on voit les voitures
officielles qui passe avec des vitres
teintées tout le monde le sait en fait
tout le monde savait que corinne aviv
est ici est que le roi venait la voir
oui une grande partie des gens le
savaient et ceux qui ne savaient pas ou
du moins ne disais pas c'était par pure
discrétion
[Musique]
voici une vue aérienne de la propriété
la maison où logera corinna à quelques
kilomètres de là le palais ou villeroy
les deux font partie du même domaine une
zone protégée est réservé aux chasse
royale la princesse corinna ils seraient
donc logés aux frais de l'état
très loin de cette image d'un couple uni
le roi et la reine serait d'après la
presse séparés depuis des années et ça
n'est pas tout
juancarlos aurait aussi des enfants
cachés la bisbal une petite ville en
catalogne
alberto ceux-là prétend être le bâtard
du roi c'est sa mère qui lui a confié
son secret elle aurait connu juan carlos
dans sa jeunesse
alberto n'avait aucune preuve de cela à
part une certaine ressemblance
jusqu'au jour où une femme l'appelle
ingrid est belge il ne la connaît pas
elle affirme elle aussi que juan carlos
et son père l'airé côté alors je ne lui
dis qu'une seule chose si juan carlos et
votre père
alors faisons un test adn ensemble et le
résultat sera positif violet je ne la
connaissais pas je n'avais même jamais
vu son visage
je lui ai juste parlé par téléphone j'ai
envoyé mon adn dans un laboratoire
ingrid a fait la même chose le test est
réalisé et le résultat est positif
d'après ce test alberto ingrid ont le
même père ils sont frères et soeurs
alberto demande alors à la justice de
réaliser un test de paternité sur juan
carlos le jugement tombe le roi ne fera
aucun test un seul argument est invoquée
issus de la constitution inviolabilité
de la personne du roi
attendez pas à ce que ce soit facile
nous j'ai même été étonné que le
jugement soit aussi rapide mais que la
juge 10 salles dans ces termes
ça ça m'a étonné elle aurait pour
rejeter la demande en disant vous n'avez
pas assez d'arguments
le dossier n'est pas assez solide sa
mort est le mal mais ça m'aurait paru
logique
laurie non non alors que l'âge elle a
utilisé un argument d'intimidation comme
moi une émanation
alberto ne fera jamais partie du clan
les bourbons une famille lourde de ses
secrets le premier de tous et peut-être
l'argent quelle est leur train de vie
réelle combien coûte-t-il vraiment aux
espagnols officiellement la famille
royale ne possède rien elle n'a pas de
patrimoine privé et ne vit que des
salaires versés par l'état
l'espagne met à sa disposition 5 fallait
dont celui de palma dans les baléares
voilà le fameux palais devant lequel la
famille pose chaque été pour les
photographes
le palais de marivent ain't 33 mille
mètres carrés de jardin une trentaine de
pièces
il n'existe aucune image de l'intérieur
via le barcelo est un élu de la région
il a accès aux comptes royaux ça les
rois ne le fait pas c'est de l'argent
public c'est le budget des baléares
c'est donc nous les habitants de palma
qui le payons de nos poches
chaque année le budget du palais tourne
autour de 2 millions d'euros
la somme inclut l'entretien du palais
mais personnel les jardiniers et les
femmes de ménage au total 23 personnes
fixe travail ici toute l'année pour un
usage de deux mois grand maximum à palma
la famille royale dispose aussi d'un
joli jouet le fortuna un bijou qui a
coûté 21 millions d'euros
avec la crise ce genre d'image faisait
mauvais effet alors depuis deux ans le
yacht a été mis au garage à l'abri des
regards
ils n'ont jamais été une famille modeste
c'est une famille qui est habitué à un
énorme train de vie et si on les voit
vivre et on sait bien que c'est le
contraire d'une famille normale
ils vivent dans le luxe ils font partie
de la jet set
des vacances de luxe combien coûte la
famille royale le reste de l'année
pendant 38 ans le budget de la couronne
a été tenu secret mais en juillet 2012
après la sphère du safari le roi décide
de faire un geste sur son site internet
il publie sur une seule page les budgets
des quatre dernières années
en 2012 la famille royale auraient reçu
8 million deux cent mille euros de
l'état
nous nous sommes intéressés au budget
d'une autre couronne celle d'angleterre
sur son site internet
elle annonce 39 millions d'euros annuels
mais le budget détaillé sur 77 pages
consommation d'électricité salaires du
personnel mêmes vins et liqueurs servi à
buckingham
la monarchie espagnole est elle vraiment
moins cher son budget serait en réalité
dix fois supérieur à celui que le roi
avance le parlement à madrid
vous êtes la honte du monde démocratique
johan tarda est un député catalan il est
le seul en espagne a osé dénoncer
l'opacité des comptes royaux
pour lui la somme déclarée par le roi ne
représente qu'une petite partie de son
budget réel
c'est en quelque sorte de leur argent de
poche pour leurs frais en fait il faut
ajouter tous les autres budgets qui les
financent de l'extérieur et qui viennent
d'autres ministères ce budget là on ne
les connaît pas réédité par exemple tous
qui a financé par le patrimoine national
l'utilisation de leurs palais moynihan
tout ce qui concerne leur sécurité les
gardes du corps payé par la défense et
l'intérieur tout ce qu'il transporte
voyages à l'étranger logistique etc
riga c'est très jaune garda a fait ses
comptes
pour lui la monarchie coûte chaque année
100 millions d'euros un chiffre
impossible à vérifier
aucune institution ne contrôler les
comptes royaux
alors tous les ans lors de la discussion
du budget johan tarda sort sa liste de
100 questions sur le coût de la couronne
comment le roi partage-t-il large entre
chaque membre de sa famille à familiale
et quelles sont ses biens propres
sur quels critères le gouvernement
détermine t-il le montant du budget pour
la famille royale
mais en vingt ans de questions pas une
seule réponse du gouvernement
leur seul argument c'est toujours le
même constitution constitution
constitution la lève comme si c'était le
coran ou alors la bible
la constitution encore garante du secret
l'article 56 dresse un rempart autour du
monarque la personne du roi est
inviolable
il n'est pas sujet à responsabilité le
monarque est au dessus des lois
il n'a de compte à rendre à personne ni
au parlement ni à la justice
le roi est intouchable mais pas sa
famille 23 février 2013
c'est un nouveau coup dur pour l'image
de juan carlos son gendre est dans le
collimateur de la justice
accompagné de son avocat il est convoqué
devant le bureau du juge
poursuivi pour avoir détourné 8 millions
d'euros d'argent public
il risque la prison c'était pourtant le
gendre idéal
un sportif de haut niveau capitaine de
l'équipe de handball médaillé olympique
à atlanta le 4 octobre 1997
le jeune basque épouse cristina la fille
cadette du roi
ce jour là le monarque l'anoblît et lui
donne le titre de duc de palma sport et
royautés le gendre du roi va marier les
deux pour gagner beaucoup d'argent en
2004 il crée une fondation nous
domicilié dans cet immeuble de barcelone
une fondation à but non lucratif censé
promouvoir l'image de l'espagne en
organisant des événements autour du
sport et du tourisme nous vend des
événements à des collectivités publiques
puis l'argent est transféré dans une
myriade de petites sociétés satellites
bâti autour de nous la fille du roi
femmes du duc de palma et propriétaire
de l'une d'entre elles
ahizoune nous lui envoie régulièrement
des virements important nous allons nous
intéresser à un des événements organisés
par la fondation novembre 2005 à palma
nous devons un forum sur le tourisme et
le sport voilà les rares photos qui
existent de l'événement quelques invités
le gendre du roi préside les débats
nous avons retrouvé la facture de ce
forum pour deux jours de discussions
nous a touché un million deux cent mille
euros
[Musique]
tony vieillesse est un élu socialiste
des baléares
à l'époque il se rend au forum organisé
par le duc de palma il comprend tout de
suite que la somme est disproportionnée
le prétexte était un débat d'experts sur
les liens entre le tourisme et le sport
il faut croire que les experts ne
l'était pas vraiment ou qui n'aiment pas
assez des battus parce que les
conclusions et est on ne peut plus
simpliste un million d'euros pour faire
une photo
ce n'est pas justifiable on s'est dit
que si un forum était aussi vides et
qu'il était si cher sans aucune facture
aucune dépense rien qui permet de les
justifier
c'est qu'il se passait quelque chose de
bizarre vous croyez que les ducs de
palma se sentaient intouchables
oui sans aucun quand une personnalité
publique comme lui demandent de l'argent
public à une administration
c'est à dire de l'argent qui vient des
impôts des gens pour un événement dont
il sait très bien qu'il ne le voit pas
parce qu'il savait très bien il se situe
délibérément en dehors des règles qui
devraient d'autant plus s'imposer à la
famille royale
pourquoi une collectivité publique offre
hôtel de telles sommes au gendre du roi
voici l'ancien patron de la région rhô
mais ma tasse
c'est lui qui a financé le forum du duc
de palma mise en examen il refuse de
répondre à nos questions pourquoi est ce
que vous ne voulez pas parler
vous pourriez vous défendre donné votre
version des faits non non je ne peux pas
vraiment non je ne peux pas je suis
désolé
il faut dire que sa dernière interview à
la télé lui a coûté très cher devant la
caméra fera aux mets ma tasse va
admettre un traitement de faveur pour le
duc de palme à l'époque des privilèges
n'est pas révolu ici il ya la place du
duc de palma c'était monsieur tout le
monde qui vous avait proposé ce qu'on
veut dans ce cas on sera passé par un
concours où on aurait fait un appel
d'offres mais avec le duc de palma non
c'est le duc de palma qu'est ce que vous
voulez dire
mais enfin c'est le duc de palma il
porte le nom il a un titre c'est un duc
alors nous ne sommes pas égaux devant la
loi
devant un président de région nous ne
sommes pas égaux je vous mentirais si je
vous disais autre chose
nous ne sommes pas égaux votre monsieur
tout le monde
je ne sais pas si je l'aurais reçu ce
n'aurait sans doute pas eu le temps
mais le duc de palma évidemment je le
reçois où il veut quand il veut
[Musique]
un début d'aveu l'interview a été versé
au dossier judiciaire
le gendre du roi profite de sa position
pour obtenir de l'argent public
il généralise la combine et les temps
sur toute l'espagne
parfois ils ne se donnent même pas la
peine d'organiser des forums bidon il se
fait payer des prestations qui n'existe
tout simplement pas il reçoit par
exemple 120 mille euros de la ville de
madrid pour un logo sportif qu'il ne
dessine ra jamais
en seulement cinq ans le gendre du roi
aurait détourné 8 millions d'euros
d'argent public
il entraîne avec lui chaque fois un peu
plus la fille du roi
[Musique]
que ces l'infante cristina des affaires
de son mari
ensemble le couple a acheté une belle
maison dans le quartier le plus chic de
barcelone
voilà les photos diffusées par l' agence
immobilière juste avant la vente
valeurs total 8 millions d'euros
une somme incompatible avec les revenus
que le couple reçoit du budget royal
c'est cette maison qui va mettre la
justice sur la piste de l'infante mais
il ya d'autres éléments
virginia lopez et l'avocate de manos
limpias une association anti-corruption
classé à l'extrême droite c'est la seule
partie civile dans ce dossier
pour elle les indices contre l'infante
sont accablants elle a connaissance de
toutes les affaires de son mari et les
preuves sont là dans le dossier elle est
porte parole de l'institut nous c'est
dans les statuts et c'est un poste
qu'elle accepte volontairement car son
nom sa signature son image ont été
utilisés pour obtenir des marchés avec
les collectivités publiques pour les
quarts
l'infante et représentante de nous est
propriétaire d'une de ses sociétés
satellites pour la justice c'en est trop
le 7 avril 2013 c'est un coup de
tonnerre
l'infante cristina est mise en examen
jamais la justice n'avait osé
s'approcher si près de la famille du roi
mais un mois plus tard marche arrière la
mise en examen est annulée à la demande
du parquet un acte rarissime sur 17
personnes mises en examen
c'est la seule à être blanchi avant même
d'être entendu josé castro et le
magistrat qui a mené l enquête
c'est juste une question c'est compliqué
d'enquêté sur la fille du roi
disons que c'est pas facile ça a été
difficile pour vous voulez plus tôt vous
avez subi des pressions n'ont aucune
pression
depuis cristina et son mari ont été
mises au ban de la famille royale seule
sortie récente une visite à l'hôpital au
chevet de juan carlos
sur le site internet de la monarchie il
existe bien des photos de l'infante lors
de ses activités officielles mais elle
date tout de 2011
quant à son mari le duc de palma son nom
a tout simplement été effacées mise en
examen il risque 10 ans de prison
son procès devrait commencer dans les
prochains mois
juan carlos est pour l'instant épargné
par ce scandale
mais après sa fille une autre de ses
proches
la fameuse corinna serait-elle aussi
impliqué par le duc de palma nous avons
récupéré un échange de mails legendre
fait des affaires avec l'ami du roi
cheikh corinna comment vas tu la saison
de la chasse c'est de la folie
ce serait intéressant de concrétiser ce
dont on a parlé
gros bisous cher iñaki j'ai eu une
réunion très intéressante avec le patron
de ma société
j'ai proposé un salaire pour toi de
200000 euros
tendresse cher corinna
j'ai oublié de t'envoyer mon rib merci
encore et gros bisous iñaki un scandale
de plus pour la famille royale
les caricaturistes s'en donnent à coeur
joie
am y est
et mieux
de l'assemblée
et alors
non même
je ne mens pas
à l'aller y'a que ça
non mais
bon ok
on choisit un vrai
la famille royale ne s'est jamais
exprimé sur ces affaires judiciaires
ce jour-là nous retrouvons le prince
héritier il inaugure une exposition de
photos
bonjour une question qui revient à l'onu
ce qu'est ce que vous saviez des
affaires de votre beau frère
pourquoi est ce que vous vous exprimez
jamais sur ces questions parfois on sort
maintenant on sort on doit sortir
maintenant attendant on va se parler
petit moment de panique la séance est
interrompue à cause de notre question
les journalistes sont évacués nous
sommes prises à l'écart je m'attends toi
tu restes là une seconde quoi je ne peux
pas poser de questions écoute moi bien
c'est très simple vous êtes là pour
faire des images les journalistes vous
restez derrière que vous nous dites rien
les cameramans les photographes
travaillent c'est des points
muet tu as déjà vu un de tes collègues
poser une question pourquoi il n'y a pas
de question parce que dans la
constitution
les rois ne peuvent pas répondre à telle
autre c'est écrit nulle part dans la
constitution
écoute la famille royale ne fait pas de
déclaration pas de déclaration pas de
comptes à rendre
la famille royale reste sur sa ligne au
risque de perdre pour de bon son contact
avec le peuple
dans la rue ils sont désormais des
milliers à rejoindre les rangs de ceux
qui manifestent contre la monarchie
l'espagne redécouvre le drapeau à bandes
violette de la république
en tête de cortège les jeunes c'est la
génération de la crise pour elle prône
carlos n'est plus le père de la nation
mais le parrain d'une monarchie
mafieuses aujourd'hui plus de la moitié
des espagnols réclament une nouvelle
constitution sans roi
la monarchie nous a beaucoup volé et
nous a beaucoup trompé pendant des
années on veut récupérer ce qui est à
nous prouver une république nous
représente tous on veut quelque chose
qu'on a choisi nous mêmes
partout en espagne défait de
républicaines sont organisées nous
retournons dans le quartier de juanjo le
chômeur déçu par le roi
mais on va essayer
moi même
ici on a même sorti la guillotine
symbole de cette envie nouvelle en finir
avec le régime
à tous ceux qui veulent la révolution
aux républicains et aux démocrates
à bas la dictature vive le peuple et
mauroy un pays sans roi la rue gronde
mais la classe politique ne bouge pas
les grands partis de droite comme de
gauche continue de penser que le roi est
indispensable à l'équilibré du pays
combien ça nous va comme pays c'est un
régime qui nous convient nous sommes un
pays très jeune démocratiquement
on avait un retard de 30 ans sur
l'europe et on a rattrapé ce retard en
quelques années c'est grâce au roi
alors ne prenons pas de risques
notre démocratie ne peut se comprendre
qu'avec la monarchie et ça pèse lourd
très lourdes dont les chars mucho
suffisamment pour dépasser les
turbulences difficile que traverse la
monarchie en ce moment et qui seront
surmontées j'espère dans quelques temps
[Musique]
des turbulences sévères qui aurait même
amené juan carlos a envisagé une
abdication au profit de son fils felipe
pour sauver sa peau la monarchie a
décidé de tout miser sur le prince
héritier à 45 ans il est
systématiquement mise en avant et
commence à se faire une place parmi les
grands
je suis très fier de ce que felipe est
devenu c'est un homme éduqué et accompli
[Musique]
séduisant moderne felipe pourrait-il
remplacer son père et sauver la
monarchie
pas sûr
ce jour là nous sommes à barcelone
felipe et letizia sont attendus à
l'opéra
sortie de voiture parmi les
applaudissements on entend les premiers
sifflets
deux simples badauds le couple en caisse
en souriant
mais pour le service de sécurité c'est
inhabituel la traditionnelle séance de
photos est annulé ok ils poseront quoi
c'est tout
sous les dorures l'impensable va se
produire
cette fois c'est la bonne société qui
sifflent
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
regard incrédule du couple princier qui
réalise peut-être à cet instant que même
les monarchies sont mortelles
[Musique]
donc